I,
I live south of Glendale and there's a,
there's a banquet hall every two blocks.
I'm like there had some laundering.
Yeah.
Come on.
That's gotta be some Geek,
some easy laundering right there.
Quit Hall.
They're just trying to figure out a way to get rid of money.
Yeah.
Cause you got to move it around just to find the ring.
Say there isn't a,
a wedding,
a two weddings a day,
couple weddings.
Sure.
Well that you got to think that if you're a person in this day and age that you
selling drugs and you're trying to launder money,
you have to be super sophisticated about it.
That's the hardest part.
If you making millions of dollars selling drugs,
how do you,
you know,
you have to own like laundromats or something.
Like you can't be like a Pablo Escobar moving the money from the bottom of the
top to the rot.
Like fruit.
Like there's so many rats in there.
I was at a,
uh,
oh this is the best way to describe the soap.
Giving anybody up.
I was at a luxury automobile place.
Ah,
and uh,
this one gentleman came in who is in the rap game.
Sure.
And,
uh,
he,
they had a large bag of money.
They were looking at Lamborghini's.
I wasn't looking at Lamborghinis today.
You do she buy the Lamborghini?
No,
but they sell them at this place.
And uh,
this guy had a bay and they were bringing out the money counter.
I'm money counting machine.
Yeah.
So like,
yeah,
like Scarface.
Scarface.
Yeah.
Like this is how they were going to buy a car.
That's fantastic.
I guess if you're in the rap game,
that's how they like to buy a car.
Sure.
They'd like to just like throw a duffle bag full of cash and buy a car and then
you're done.
You're done.
It's like,
no,
I wait my wire to come through.
No,
here you go.
I,
uh,
my,
I used to work with a business manager who used to work with high end sports.
Uh,
it's high on the athletes and she's like,
oh yeah,
like I was just like,
can you eat,
set this up or some transfer?
She's like,
Nah,
listen,
you'll never make my job as hard as trying to get a Lamborghini dealer to open
at midnight in Las Vegas where the client wants to buy one.
Oh,
right.
Like somebody wins.
Yeah.
There's something going.
It's like,
I want to buy a lambo right now.
Coked out of their fucking mind how to get married.
I'm going to buy a limb.
Brightening.
Got Purple.
Who was that pictures his future.
He's the rappers to him.
Hold on $1 million future.
His future is very,
very popular.
There is future and it looks like he's got some stray hundreds in that.
A ring finger slipping through his fingers.
Do you think he has like a fuck hole cut in the,
in the money,
right?
He's fucking,
that really was.
Pants are down very low and see known as it may.
Good,
good point.
Hey,
might be,
uh,
might have a fleshlight in paled into that stack of cash.
So he's got $1 million in cash.
How much have that Mike Tyson back in the height of his,
of his is heavyweight reign.
He used to carry like something like $20,000 on a middle times or something
insane.
That's normal,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Well it's for a rapper at 20 grand is,
that's not funny,
but I'm talking the eighties but I remember reading that article as a kid and
being like Christ and I went through two thoughts.
Isn't the afraid of getting around?
Of course not.
Of course.
Not Rob Mike Tyson,
like usually he's going to find you unless you kill him.
He's gonna.
He's gonna find he's going to sit on you and punch your head until it's jelly.
What is it says broke.
Yeah.
That was after 57 file for bankruptcy.
Right,
because like women were coming after him for child support.
So he said he was bankrupt,
but he also made hundreds of millions of dollars off of vitamin water.
Yeah.
He made a killing with that vitamin water deal.
He's got some weird bankruptcy thing.
It was,
it was child support.
Is that what got him in the end and vodka because no,
I don't think got him.
I,
he was avoiding it.
He never should have wrapped.
Have a baby by me,
baby,
be a millionaire.
I'll write the check for the baby comes.
Who the fuck cares?
I think he said that says,
I mean,
you're setting yourself up there.
I guess he cares.
Yeah.
Well the thing is after a while,
when you don't have a hit record out in like a decade,
right.
You're like,
hey,
this shit could dry up.
Yeah.
Like maybe I need to go bankrupt and stop paying these ladies.
He's,
well,
it's a cash only business.
He probably has it all hidden.
I don't know what he did.
Like he bought the vitamin water thing isn't cash only.
I don't know how,
I don't know how that guy is a dollar spend.
So you're bankrupt.
That's sticky.
Really is I think,
I think your theory is probably sound of him just being like,
yeah,
I don't,
ah.
I think it was literally because of that,
like someone was trying to hit him up either for alimony or child support.
He was like,
I've got an idea.
I'm just going to hire some financial wizards.
Sorcery.
Yeah.
Dig a hole,
bury it in the ground.
It is weird that people give people money.
Like,
like you break up and go,
okay,
well now you've got to give them money.
Like I get it if you have a child to support.
Totally makes sense.
Right.
But like if you dated someone for a couple of years and then you married him and
then while you're married,
you made $1 million,
they didn't make anything and be like,
Hey,
I want to have that money.
Like what is very straight and not together anymore.
Yeah.
But uh,
I want money.
I want money from you.
Check story.
Are you going to do half my set on the road for now on?
No,
no,
no.
But I want you to support my lifestyle.
Oh,
I'm used to a certain lifestyle.
That's another thing that gets me,
that's used to a certain lifestyle.
That guy,
the guy who,
uh,
Joan Collins,
I don't know,
16th husband or something.
I remember he,
that was his thing in court.
Like your honor,
my client has grown accustomed to a certain lifestyle and that was all over the
news and it was just like,
ah,
come on dude.
Custom,
like you can't change,
you cannot change.
Right.
There's no way you could live a middle class life anymore.
It's that those days are done.
Okay.
It's awkward.
It's only upward.
Well,
you probably can't,
you can't fly anything less than FirstClass now can't you?
Probably I float.
Yeah,
sometimes good for you.
Yeah.
It's just a fucking plane.
Yeah,
that's good.
But I know people that if they have to sit and like,
I remember when,
when,
uh,
during the whatever recession or something,
there's some video of puff daddy getting on a plane and he was like,
he's like,
your boy isn't flying private.
We've got to fix these problems,
man.
I've got to fly in first class.
And you just like,
why would I give a shit?
You're boy isn't flying private.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Thank you.
Thank you for tweeting about this.
I was worried about the government shutdown and yelling at yelling at us,
and this was like 10 years ago,
but like yelling at the,
at the,
whoever's filming them on Tmz and,
and I think about the person that's in like group D for that plane where they
call you and it's just like you and like a stray dog that gets led on the plane.
Was he saying he wasn't flying private because the money wasn't flowing because
the economy was low?
Yeah,
that was his point.
Yeah.
And there's someone that's like,
oh,
I used my last check to get on this plane to see about a job offer and Tulsa.
Oh Jesus.
He's one of those guys.
Like he had some fucking billboard on sunset.
It was like,
can't stop.
Won't stop.
I thought you stopped.
I didn't know you didn't stop.
[inaudible] I thought I told you that.
We don't stop.
Can't stop.
Won't stop.
It's like,
yeah,
we told you that.
We don't stop.
We,
you told us we put them on stop.
Stop.
I haven't seen you in awhile.
You didn't stop.
Yeah.
While we've been doing,
while he wasn't around,
he didn't stop.
What does he do?
It was 2008 because the gas prices were too high,
so he stopped flying private.
That's what it was.
Thank you.
Gas prices.
It wasn't okay.
Economy.
Got To fix this problem for puff daddy or PTSD or whatever that is.